hi YouTube my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen let me
just pull it up real fast just one
moment just one second yep there it is
so I put up the poll on my twitter
asking what the next Tamara's never seen
should be and I said monster squad
scream poltergeist or scary movie
knowing full well the Monster Squad was
going to win
why because so many people were like
watch monster squad ever please watch it
and then scream one don't get me wrong
I'm excited to see scream I've seen
pretty much any other slasher 90s horror
film that was out there scream just it
eluded me it escaped my grasp
this has shown me that a lot of y'all
don't follow me on twitter follow me
Tamara L chambers on Twitter go make one
right now no it's okay don't do what you
want to do but poles go up there I'll
probably be watching Monster Squad for
my personal channel this month I'm doing
a bunch of Halloween themed videos but
today we are going to look at the 1996
horror classic scream scary movie was
also on that poll because I've not seen
any of those films and I feel like as a
horror lover I should watch some
parodies of horror and I got a lot of
tweets from people being like do not
watch scary movie without watching
scream first and I was never going to I
know I know how things work sometimes
not really okay but I'll probably be
doing a scary movie on my channel as
well I tweeted about to watch scream
send me those predictions and make them
9 DZ which is a scientific term I'm so
excited to watch scream and hopefully be
scared and hopefully scream hooray let's
do it yeah
towba fest oh man that was nineties II I
overall really enjoyed that I don't know
how I found a lot of comedy in this even
though I was going into this thinking
that this is the one I needed to see
before I watched scary movie but this
one had a lot of like it tongue and
cheek like jabs at horror films to which
I love all the callbacks to the West
Craven films and like jabbing at him the
tropes in horror films and it was really
clever really funny I laughed out loud
which is something I love to do in
horror films is it eases a little bit of
tension but also like it's just like oh
what was the scary coming down ha ha you
know you get it and over and over again
the first thing I wrote down is Drew
Barrymore oh my god I love her lipstick
hold up so the killer on the phone is
supposed to be creepy I know this you
know this we all know this but he really
just sounds like a therapist with a head
cold what's that sound Oh popcorn
delicious what's your favorite movie oh
yes we eat me too then he starts to
sound like a weird internet commenter
want to go out what's your name don't
hang up on me then he calls her a bitch
so internet commenter then he critiques
the way that she answers the door
internet commenter oh my god then he
kills her boyfriend because she gets
movie trivia wrong internet commenter
this feels like a personal attack
against me oh then she dad
so bummer the drew Barrymore died so
quickly I really enjoyed her in this
small part that she had but she made
some major scary movie mistakes sorry
girl r.i.p alright p truth then you cut
to the typical 90's couple depict it in
film guy i'm gonna have sex girl no
thanks guy okay let's make out that I'm
definitely gonna cross some barriers oh
it's the Fonz and jean-ralphio dad
I wrote oh and also sexist shaggy what a
delight and then right under that oh
he's the killer
right dot-dot-dot yeah he's pretty sure
the killer Sydney gets a call from the
killer and the situation is scary but
his voice is not scary it's very lame
but she is a badass horror legend
yes Sydney girl yes a lot of my notes
are just rapid lines and succession of
like I adore Courtney Cox's yellow suit
I do not adore that she's a dick to fat
people oh hell yes and he punched her
hell yeah Sydney thinks that her
boyfriend is the one who was calling and
who is the killer because he showed up
right after she was on the phone with
him and she's proved to not be the
killer but he starts blaming her
mother's death on her intimacy issues
saying that she needs to get over it
because it's been a year dick gasped
douche as big dick it's best I could do
there's a lot of moments in this film
that are very typical whores and the 90s
she runs to bathroom goes into a stall
and these two girls come out and they're
talking about her and she just stays in
there I would have confronted him I
don't like confrontation so I wouldn't
have confronted them with words but
maybe one of those Courtney Cox punches
I love that the janitor is named Fred
and he's dressed as Freddy Krueger the
film is filled with those moments and it
just makes me so happy and giddy inside
oh they're so self-aware and fun and
great and there are moments of surreal
earnest I imagine it was scarier when it
came out not scary to me now but fun it
wasn't upsetting to me in a way that a
lot of horror films are my next note is
just oh no the phone's dead Tatom
Sidney's best friend walks into the
garage to grab some beers
and I yelled oh no I've seen this I've
definitely seen the garage-door seen on
like a youtube video compilation of
scary movie scenes or something I don't
remember where I don't remember when I
don't remember how but I have seen it I
love it though I think it's a great
scene I love that she gets trapped in
the garage door I love that this garage
door is strong enough to do that mine
from back home was really slow so I
literally could have just held it and it
would have been fine after everyone dies
I'm just gonna say it like I did with
the Fonz
oh no the fun stuff oh no Tatum I didn't
want to lie Courtney Cox's character but
I loved her with the Cobb I loved him
they were so sweet together
kiss kiss so Sid is feeling the pressure
of having sex with her boyfriend and she
finally says yes they have sex and then
her boyfriend is probably killed as his
tradition I thought it was killed
spoilers he's not so the killer is
running around stabbing everyone this is
just a stab party it was a regular party
now it's a stab party everyone's dying
oh no everyone died Sydney gets stabbed
which is Wow first stab of the night
first stab of the night am i right do we
get stabbed oh no do we you're supposed
to date Courtney cops then the reveal of
the killer happens we all go a little
mad well Wow I really thought I called
it and I did not I knew it was shaggy
I knew it was him because he was crazy
and like never around but I thought they
were making it so obvious that it was
the boyfriend that it was gonna be like
nope it was Shaggy Olive ugh
no is both of them it's the boyfriend
and Shaggy sexist shaggy like zoinks
Scoob the movie references wow
throughout the film were really
delightful to me now at the very end are
a little much like to really cramming
him down here throat your mom was no
Sharon Stone Hannibal Lecter likes to
eat people movie things Sid is a badass
though and she totally prevails and I
love the tune on virgin women and one
virgin male
live I love that do you hard movie
tropes I just learned oh hell yeah do he
lives he will live to be adorable
another day there are 212 predictions
the slip get into those ya roses a
badass you'll wonder if David Arquette
appears in any more good films spoiler
alert
no it's you Dewey I don't know who
people are oh god I'm gonna search it he
was doing you'll wonder how Ghostface
kills anyone when he's the clumsiest
slasher ever yes how what huh first of
all the Sidney have any fight training
because she is way more poised and way
more powerful than him he just has a
knife both of them both of them
apparently cuz they're both terrible and
they fall and they are really bad
dodging things and they're awful killers
you'll want to cosplay as drew Barrymore
with her giant sweater you will freaking
love Sidney I'm probably way too late on
this but this is my favorite horror
movie I hope you love it Tamra thank
Samantha Jackson I did love it after
Roses West carpenter joke you'll realize
how lame medic humor was in the 90s at
least as written by Kevin Williamson oh
I liked it
uh-huh but I'm pretty lame so it's
probably why thank you so much for
watching everyone
next week I'm doing poltergeist as the
poll suggested Oh
I'll see you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
you